rérévélation des premières imags
dudu télescope spatial James We,
cecelui-ci pourrait déjà avoir
trtrouvé la galaxie la plus
didistante jamais observée, qui
exexistait il y a 13,5 milliards
d'd'années. Pour en savoir  sur
cecette découverte extraordinaie
avavec nous René Doyon
asastrophysicien à l'Universitée
MoMontréal, directeur de
l'l'Observatoire de Lac-Méganti,
didirecteur de l'Institut de
rerecherches sur les exoplanètes
BoBonjour.
- - Bonjour.
- - Que représente cette nouvele
gagalaxie appelée GLASS-z 13?
EsEst-ce un record en astronomi?
CeCette nouvelle galaxie est
apappelée  GLASS-z13, elle nous
apapparaît telle qu'elle était
seseulement environ 300 millions
d'd'années après le big-bang, st
10100 millions d'années de moins
quque le précédent record obser.
- - Écoutez, d'abord c'est une
gagalaxie candidate elle n'est s
enencore confirmée d'être cette
didistance mais elle a toute
l'l'allure d'être une galaxie ts
lolointaine alors elle a été
obobtenue avec James Webb alors
leles chercheurs de Harvard dist
ququ'il s'est une galaxie qui
reremonte à 13,5 milliards
d'd'années on se rappelle que le
bibig-bang a été formé il y a 18
mimilliards d'années lorsqu'on
reregarde loin en regardant le
tetemps. Ça a tout l'allure d'êe
unune galaxie très lointaine qun
dedevra confirmer avec d'autres
ininformations qui viendra très
bibientôt.
- - Comment on peut en arriver à
fafaire cette hypothèse?
- - C'est-à-dire que les galaxie
onont des couleurs très
paparticulières et donc en les
obobservant dans différentes
cocouleurs comme on peut voir
ququelles raison cette apparenc,
etet c'est une analyse
paparticulière qu'il faut faire
mamais encore une fois c'est une
gagalaxie candidate et il faut
vrvraiment confirmer hélas cette
didistance il faut vraiment
prprendre le spectre microscopie
etet prendre la distance de la
lulumière. Et je précise aussi e
l'l'article a été soumis et n'a
papas été en revue par les pair.
NoNormalement on soumet un artie
alalors il y a tellement de
frfrénésie avec James Webb alors
leles gens sont très impatientsl
y y a une un élément de courses
ququi veulent être les premiers
leles chercheurs de Harvard a
dédécidé de mettre les leur
ararticle public mais il faut
atattendre que l'Arctique soit
acaccepté et surtout confirmer a
prprendra des observations
StStrateco scopique. D'ailleurse
tétélescope canadien sera mis à
cocontribution.
- - Et il y a plein d'astronomeà
trtravers la planète qui plonge
dédéjà là dessus pour essayer de
coconfirmer ce qui est écrit das
l'l'Arctique. Ce qu'on dit c'est
quque cette galaxie candidate ns
apapparaît telle qu'elle était l
y y a 300 millions d'années aprs
lele big-bang. Qu'est-ce que ça
pepeut nous dire ça concernant e
bibig-bang?
- - C'est une des missions les
plplus importantes de James Webb
c'c'est de comprendre comment ls
gagalaxies se sont formées avece
bibig-bang la théorie du big-bag
didit que l'univers est formé iy
a a trois 13,8 milliards d'annés
mamais qu'il n'y avait rien
seseulement du gaz et ils y
avavaient des régions plus denss
etet tout cela s'est effondré ls
prpremières lumières étoile et
gagalaxies se sont allumés maisn
nene sait pas très bien comme ça
s's'est passé donc déjà on voit
unune galaxie candidate à 13,5
mimilliards d'années donc 300
mimillions d'années après le bi-
babang et ça suggère qu'il y ena
d'd'autres qui sont plus jeunes
ququi pourraient être là encore.
DoDonc encore une fois il faudra
coconfirmer d'autres données y e
tétélescope James Webb à toute a
pupuissance pour confirmer cela.
EtEt ça pourrait se faire dans s
prprochaines semaines.
- - En attendant on garde une
cecertaine prudence parce qu'on
n'n'a pas confirmation
scscientifique. Il James Webb ns
réréserve pendant 20 ans encore
dedes découvertes cosmiques assz
susurprenantes
- - absolument, ça ne fait que
cocommencer.
- - On va suivre cela avec un